David Boder: [In English] Chicago, June the 26th, 1950, project MH156. This is reproduction Spool 9-21A, Dr. Maximilian Lipschitz. It is the first half of Spool 21.
David Boder: August the 4th, Rue de Patin [checks recorder]...August the 4th, Rue, 9 Rue de Patin, in a home for adult deportees. Paris, August 4th, 1946, at Rue Patin, number 9, in a home for adult Jews. We are going to interview Dr. Maximilian Lipschitz, eh, age thirty-five. This is Spool 21.
David Boder: [In German] Eh, also, sagen Sie mir, wieder, sagen Sie uns, was ist Ihr voller Name?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Dr. Maximilian Lipschitz.
David Boder: Und, eh, wo sind Sie geboren, Dr. Lipschitz?
Maximillian Lipschitz: In Neuschonstau.
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Das ist in der Tschechoslowakei.
David Boder: Ja. Eh, und, eh, wo, hm, und wo haben Sie studiert?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ich habe in Prag studiert.
David Boder: Und, eh, Ihren Doktor haben Sie in welchem Fach?
Maximillian Lipschitz: In Naturwissenschaften, und hauptsächlich Chemie.
David Boder: In Naturwissenschaften, hauptsächlich Chemie. [inaudible, pause]
David Boder: Also, sprechen Sie ein bissel lauter, und wollen Sie uns sagen, wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg angefangen hat und was hat dann passiert?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Als der Krieg anfing, war ich in Krakau, weil ich da meine Familie hatte, mein Kind, das sechs Wochen alt war, und meine Schwester.
David Boder: Und Ihre Frau?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Meine Frau war schon vor dem Krieg gestorben. Ich hatte dort meine Familie und lebte eine Zeit, eh, verhältnismäßig, eh, ungestört, bis die größeren, eh, Verfolgungen anfingen. Im Dezember 1939 fing es an mit verschiedenen Registrierungen, und eh, auch eh, und dann, im Dezember, mit den, eh, mit den, mit der Vorschrift, eh, einen, ein Band mit dem Judenstern am rechten Arm zu tragen. Dann kamen die verschiedenen Verbote, mit der Bahn zu fahren, die Verbote—diese...
David Boder: Mit welcher Bahn, außer der Stadt oder in der Stadt?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Mit der, mit der, eh, Staatsbahn zu fahren, mit der Eisenbahn.
David Boder: Ja.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Dann kamen, eh, die Verbote, selbständig Geschäfte zu führen, auf, eh, Beamtenstellen zu sein, so dass die Juden immer gedrückter und gedrückter in ihren, eh, Wohnverhältnissen und in ihren Lebensverhältnissen wurden. Eine Zeit durften Juden noch in den größeren Städten wohnen, dann wurde es immer gedrückter, und bis 1941 waren die Juden hauptsächlich in meister Städten Polens in Ghettos zusammengepfercht.
David Boder: Ja, also, erzählen Sie bloß von Ihrer Stadt, und wo Sie waren und was dort passiert hat.—Sie waren also in Krakau?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ich war in Krakau, im Jahre 1942 waren wir schon, alle Juden, die in, eh, Krakau, in Krakau Umgebung wohnten, hauptsächlich im Krakauer Ghetto, eh, zusammen ge-, zusammen gedrückt.
David Boder: Ja, eh, nun beschreiben Sie etwas das Ghetto und wie hat man das Ghetto gemacht und weiter?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Das Ghetto wurde in ein, in Podgórze errichtet, das eh, eine Vorstadt von Krakau, dort wurden auf einem ganz kleinen, eh, auf einer, auf einem ganz kleiner Raum die cirka 15.000 Juden, die in der Stadt gelassen wurden, in sehr engen Wohnverhältnissen zusammen gedrückt.
David Boder: Haben dort Juden bevor gewohnt?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Es haben auch Juden vorher dort gewohnt, aber die Wohnungen wurden von den Gästen die dort vorher wohnten eh, ausgeräumt,
David Boder: Ja.
Maximillian Lipschitz: . . . und die Juden wurden in ganz engen Wohnverhältnissen zusammen gerückt—so dass in einem Zimmer cirka drei, vier Menschen wohnten.
David Boder: Nun?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Und auch mehr. Ich wohnte zum Beispiel in einem ziemlich großen Zimmer, da wohnten wir 12 Personen.
David Boder: Ja.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Da wohnte allerdings, da wohnte drei Kinder...
David Boder: Alle Männer?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Nein, Familien, Fremde und so weiter.
David Boder: Männer und Frauen darunter?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Männer und Frauen und Kinder in einem...
David Boder: In einem Zimmer...
Maximillian Lipschitz: . . . in einem Zimmer.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, wovon hat man gelebt?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Leben durfte man nur von der Arbeit, die einem die Deutschen anbieteten, das war hauptsächlich, eh, in Fabriken als Arbeiter, hauptsächlich in Rüstungsfabriken, in Militärwerkstätten, und...
David Boder: Und haben die für die Arbeit bezahlt?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Die haben für die Arbeit so bezahlt, aber so, dass man nur da förmlich davon leben konnte, und hauptsächlich leben konnte man nur davon, dass man Sachen, die man noch hatte, irgendwie, Bettzeug oder Töpfe, verkaufen ging und von dem Erlös der Waren lebte.
David Boder: Zu wem hat man das verkauft?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Das hat man an Polen verkauft.
David Boder: Das hat man an die Polen verkauft.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ja.
David Boder: Eh, war es für die Juden spezielles Geld, war es Ghettogeld dort?
Maximillian Lipschitz: In Krakau war kein spezielles Geld.
David Boder: Ja.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Das war in Lodz, ne, das waren...
David Boder: In Lodz war es Ghettogeld...
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ja, das war Lodz, ja.
David Boder: Nun, also, so haben Sie mit zwölf Leuten in einem Zimmer gewohnt. Wer war mit Ihnen von Ihren Verwandten?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ich war noch mit meiner Schwester, und Schwager, ein Kind von mir, zwei Kinder von meiner Schwester...
David Boder: Ja.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Dann war noch, eh, eine, ein Cousin von mir mit Frau und Kind...
David Boder: Ja, und?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ein Onkel und eine Tante...
David Boder: Ja. Und warn auch noch mit Fremde mit...?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Und warn auch Fremde mit Familie, fremde, fremde Menschen noch dabei.
David Boder: Also, wie hat man geschlafen?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Man, eh, es warn entweder Betten da, und wenn kein Platz war, warn wir auch, eh, haben wir auf der Erde schlafen müssen.
David Boder: Nun, also weiter.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ich habe in einer Fabrik gearbeitet, in einer Gießerei, musste schon, falls ich weg war, das, eh, sehr weit von der Stadt draußen war, ich habe Gieß-, an einer Zinkgieß-, an einer Zink, einer —-gießerei [unverständlich] gearbeitet, und habe cirka 80 / 90 Zloty die Woche verdient, das reichte kaum, um, um das Brot für die zwei, die zwei, drei Tage zu kaufen.
David Boder: Also, gehen Sie weiter. Ja?
Maximillian Lipschitz: In diesen schlechten Zeiten hielten wir aus bis Mai 1942. Im Mai 1942 kamen die ersten Vorgänge, die wir überhaupt nicht erwartet haben. Das warn die Aussiedlungen.
David Boder: Nun, beschreiben Sie in Einzelheiten die Prozedur der Aussiedlungen dort. Hm?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Es wurden, es wurde das Ghetto gesperrt, ringsherum waren, eh, SS Waffen, die keinen Menschen ins Ghetto herein und auch keinen heraus ließen. Es wurden alle Menschen registriert, wer eine Bestätigung hatte, ein— in einem Rüstungsbetrieb arbeitete, wurde, bekam einen, eine Bestätigung, dass er bleiben darf, die andern wurden auf einem Platz versammelt, wurden weg geführt.
David Boder: Haben Sie die Bescheinigung bekommen?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ich hatte damals die Bescheinigung bekommen, weil ich in der Gießerei arbeitete.
David Boder: Ja.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Es waren aber viele Leute, die auch bei Deutschen arbeiteten, in Werkstätten, und die durch diese verschiedenen, eh, Wirrwarr in der Stadt so auch, eh, auch auf den Sammelplatz kamen und auch weg geführt wurden. Bis...
David Boder: Also, jetzt kommt Ihre Familie, eh, ist ihre Familie mit Ihnen zusammen geblieben?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Es ist mir damals gelungen, für, eh, meine Schwester und für, für mein Kind und für die Schwester der Kinder die Bestätigung zu bekommen, das war das erste Mal, sonst wurden noch die Familienmitglieder der Arbeiter berücksichtigt, und, eh, wurden noch da gelassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Damals wurden cirka—
David Boder: Wohin wurden die Leute weg geführt?
Maximillian Lipschitz: . . . fünf- bis zehntausend Menschen weg geführt...
David Boder: Ja. Wohin?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Nach unseren späteren Erkundigungen wurde uns gesagt, dass sie nach Belzec geführt wurden, wo eine Vernichtungsfabrik war. Wir selbst im Ghetto wussten cirka drei bis vier Monate überhaupt nichts von dem Los dieser Menschen. Und, eh, noch eins und zwei Jahre nachher kamen verschiedene Gerüchte zu uns, die wahrscheinlich von den Deutschen aufgebracht waren, dass die Menschen nach dem Trainer [unverständlich] geführt wurden und dort arbeiteten im Lager, das war aber nicht wahr. Denn wir haben später [geräusch], zwei, drei, vier Jahre später erfahren, dass die Menschen, alle wie sie waren, in die Vernichtungsfabriken geführt wurden, und, eh, dort verbrannt oder vergast wurden.
David Boder: Ja, was hat das, Sie sagen, verbrannt, hat man nicht, eh, bloß die Toten verbrannt?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ja, das, eh—ich habe auch später im Lager und nach der Befreiung Menschen getroffen, die in diesen Lagern selbst gearbeitet haben. Die Szenen, die mir geschildert wurden, waren gar nicht, sind gar nicht wieder zu geben, kaum glaublich, dass ein Mensch, ein Menschengehirn sich solche Plan erdacht- erdenken konnte.
David Boder: Also?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Es wurden Menschen zum Teil in den, ne, in einen Raum, in einen dichten Raum gepackt, die Menschen waren vom Transport schon halbtot, sie wurden zusammen gepresst, und die Gas-, eh, Gas-, eh -gefäße wurden geöffnet. Wenn nicht genug Gasgefäße waren, waren die Menschen kaum, eh, vom Gas, eh, erstickt, sondern nur halbtot, und wie sie waren, wurden sie in den Feuerraum gebracht und dort verbrannt.
David Boder: Was nennen Sie einen Feuerraum?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Nun—Krematorium.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, also, wollen wir zurück kommen, Sie sind damals dann in Krakau geblieben?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ich bin damals in Krakau geblieben. Nach dieser, nach der ersten Aussiedlung im Mai wurde das Ghetto verkleinert, weil dort weniger Juden waren. Die Verhältnisse wurden noch schlechter. Dann kam im—Oktober 1942, kam die zweite Aussiedlung. Da wurden schon Familienmitglieder nicht mehr berücksichtigt. Damals verlor ich den größten Teil meiner Familie. Es gelang mir nur zufällig, meine Schwester und die Kinder zu retten...
David Boder: Wer kamen von Ihrer Familie verloren?
Maximillian Lipschitz: Damals, also bei der ersten Aussiedlung verlor ich Onkel, eine Tante, ein Cousin, einen jungen Menschen mit seiner Frau und einem 14-jährigen Mädchen. Alles blühende Menschen, die noch lange hätten leben können.
David Boder: Ja, nun.
Maximillian Lipschitz: Ich war natürlich nicht die Einzigen, es warn, wenn man nach der Aussiedlung durch die Stadt, die Straßen des Ghettos ging, da hörte man nur das Weinen und...[pause]
David Boder: [In English] This interview was discontinued because Dr. Lipschitz had to go on an important appointment of which he either had forgotten or didn’t know before. We are now introducing another interview, at, eh, about the, eh, fourteenth minute of the spool.
David Boder: Chicago, June 26th, 1950. This concludes the section of Dr. Lipschitz. We have separated this from Spool 21, that has now the interview with Mr. Lea, and this will be Spool 9-21A, while the interview with Mr. Lea will be Spool 9-21B. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording, project MH156. That’s all.